nuit en refuge emmanuel macron à
contempler les dégâts bien visible sur
le mont blanc sur la mer de glace d'eau
glacée qui a reculé de 120 m en un
siècle le chef de l'état entend se
servir de cette séquence comme un point
d'appui de sa politique environnementale
communication vrai tournant écologique
à gauche on est assez unanimes en tout
cas là c'est un sommet de la foutaise
pour moi tu es là le mont louis saha
sommet de l'hypocrisie qui n'est pas
président du conseil départemental de
haute savoie avec un enjeu majeur mais
oui au fond on a encore quelques années
oui le statu quo est une option un peu
de technologie si un peu de croissance
là et puis quelques mesures annonce
alors ça nous permettra d'attendre un
peu peut-être que dans la semaine y aura
mâcon à la plage mais l'arrêté maquereau
à la montagne dans une espèce de resucée
assez médiocre d'ushuaïa nature
et pourtant c'est pas faute pour le
président de la république d'avoir
employé cet après midi des mots lourds
de sens celui de notre capacité à
inventer mais nouvelle manière de vivre
d'habiter de faire
jean mathieu pernin on vient donc
d'entendre le chef de l'état c'était il
ya quelques heures sur le mont blanc ou
dans le coin est-ce qu'on a des raisons
objectives de douter de la bonne foi du
président la république bat un peu en
fait joli parce que rafa qu'il est en
fait il a trop joué avec emmanuel macron
c'est le problème c'est que il s'en est
tellement servi notamment contre donald
trump
il a même été je passe dans la paix par
l'onu champion de la planète il a reçu
le titre officiel champion de la planète
comme dans un film de super héros de
manuel macron c'était en 2018 les
français ne comprenait pas pourquoi à
l'international on le voyait comme un
champion de la planète est chez nous by
que finalement il y avait pas énormément
de résultats alors c'est sûr que les
résultats en matière d'environnement
ça prend du temps mais le bilan quoi
qu'on en dise il n'est pas
extraordinaire un emmanuel macron il
s'est présenté et tant mieux au départ
avec énormément de gages
environnementaux et pour l'instant bas
sur le nucléaire la part qui devait
passer à 50%
ce n'est pas le cas les usines là
charles les centrales à charbon sont pas
fermées et la fermeture de fessenheim
que ce soit ça a commencé quand même
très tôt sa fermeture en effet sous
françois hollande et en plus surtout on
voit aussi bien au niveau du glyphosate
on sait très bien que ça va pas sortir
tout de suite les pesticides bref il ya
tellement d'arrangement je trouve ça un
peu dur de dire oui mad men macron halal
c'est le conseil général de haute savoie
comme a dit françois roussin parce que
ça n'a rien à voir
il peut aller en effet constaté c'est
terrible c'est à reculer voilà de son
mât mais dans 30 ans voilà on n'a jamais
vu ça mais emmanuel macron je pense que
c'est un peu tard pour dire aujourd'hui
regardez comme je suis écolo parce que
je pense qu'il a beaucoup je mets père
noël emmanuel macron ceci la fin de
notre dame des landes tout à fait
exactement notre dame des landes mais
vous savez c'est je pense qu'il a raté
vraiment un coup exactement comme
nicolas sarkozy qui aurait pu convertir
son camp véritablement avant tout le
monde à l'environnement quand il avait
signé ce pacte avec nicolas hulot en
2007 quand il a été élu et bah quand il
a commencé à dire l'environnement ça
suffit au sein de l'agriculture l'homme
a perdu du temps là on perd de nouveau
du temps avec emmanuel macron parce
qu'on ne sait pas trop où il veut aller
et donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
peu tard je suggère qu'il doit être
il est assez engageant dans dedans mais
c'est un peu tard celui de ravinel
est-ce que la fin de sa crédibilité
juste elle date pas de nicolas hulot qui
s'en va si bien sûr d'une certaine façon
vous avez parlé de notre dame des landes
c'est vrai que c'était le geste fort
d'un début de mandat qui est aussi été
lié à ce qui s'était passé avant il
n'était pas complètement les nulle part
nicolas hulot bien sûr qu'il ya qui a
marqué les choses mais aussi mathieu
orphelin de façon plus plus plus précise
au sein même de son parce qu'on peut
imaginer que nicolas hulot aussi la
déception d'un rôle personnel dans un
appareil un rôle politique qui était pas
le sien enfin voilà matthieu orphelin
c'est différent il y avait une vraie
conviction écologique derrière et
j'entendais ce matin les réactions du
wwf et franchement c'est pas des punks
en matière d'écologie et qui disait que
les annonces n'étaient pas à la hauteur
des enjeux et que si le discours était
martial les actions derrière les gestes
ne correspondait pas forcément il suffit
d'aller voir en europe la ratification
de deux je cherche le nom au vietnam de
cet accord voilà de l'accord commercial
avec le vietnam qui est quand même
symboliquement très fort et qui a été
ratifié par tous ceux qui étaient censés
pascal canfin en premier incarnez
justement se voit là après on peut avoir
des positions différentes sur l'écologie
sur ce qu'elle doit être
christian jacob a donné son avis en
disant qu'il fallait concilier
l'écologie et le productivisme ce qui
peut être relativement remis en cause
puisque la base de l'écologie est quand
même une remise en cause justement du
productivisme
ce qui n'a pas de rapport avec ce que
dit emmanuel macron qui lui a parlé
d'une écologie qui doivent être
compatibles avec le progrès économique
ce qui n'est pas totalement faux ni
d'ailleurs avec la science était à la
base de son de son de son programme en
mais de fait sont que des gestes c'est
très symbolique d'être allé là je pense
que tous les français il a eu bien
raison parce qu'en matière de
communication politique c'est sans doute
le lieu le plus emblématique le plus
marquant en france le réseau via un
climat cryptée vous dites il a raison
mais c'est pas tout à fait l'avis de
ceux qui nous suivent si nicolas elle
nous dit me dis pas tu qu'il fallait que
macro et ya un ministre suffisait
largement
je pense pas si effectivement l'enjeu
est si fort c'était à lui de se déplacer
là-bas et babineau new deal emmanuel
macron à observer la montée des verts
lors des dernières européennes c'est un
coup de com pour attirer mais ça c'est
une évidence les électeurs c'est une
évidence a renouvellé douce et puis
l'eau sert les sondages ou donc
certainement ou de vie le les verts sont
donnés gagnants et conquérant dans un
certain nombre de grandes métropoles qui
sont des métropoles qui en plus avaient
plutôt voté emmanuel macron donc bien
évidemment il ya aussi cet agenda
politique qui compte dans la
communication politique et c'est pas un
gros mot je le dis d'emmanuel macron sur
ce sujet le problème c'est si vous
voulez il ya deux sujets en effet je
suis assez d'accord avec vous il a
survendu
il a énormément survendu et il est
depuis finalement le départ de nicolas
hulot qui a claqué la porte avec pertes
et fracas en train de courir en
permanence a pas derrière cette derrière
cette promesse et il a beaucoup de mal
parce que in fine et on se rend compte
que sur un certain nombre de sujets par
exemple la réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre la france est assez
en retard même sur la question de
l'office français de la biodiversité qui
est créé qui réunit deux structures qui
existent et on voit que notamment le
budget de l'une de ces structures a
diminué c'est l'office je crois de la
chasse et de la nature
donc si vous voulez il ya des signes il
ya des signaux qui ont été envoyés qui
ne correspond pas finalement au fond du
discours d' emmanuel macron et puis
vient le problème vous l'avez
bigné qui à mon avis un problème de fond
c'est qu emmanuel macron il s'inscrit
quand même par sa culture économique
passèrent culture politique dans un dans
un modèle qui est le modèle
productiviste et quand on regarde
l'histoire de l'écologie l'histoire de
l'écologie politique depuis que
l'écologie politique existe depuis 40
ans voire un demi siècle
l'écologie politique elle s'est bâtie
quand même fondamentalement contre ce
modèle alors il veut acculturés il veut
la culture et si vous voulez au
libéralisme ou acculturés plutôt le
libéralisme à l'écologie voix culture et
d'écologie et au libéralisme mais à un
moment donné
finalement c'est difficile à mettre en
oeuvre et il est quelque part un peu
gêné aux entournures de ce point de vue
là et puis de toute façon il ya un
électorat verts qui préférera toujours
l'original à la copie
on peut pas être conservateur et vert
c'est assez compliqué on peut être
conservateur peut-être et vert est-ce
qu'on peut être libéral et vert connaît
traditions sont bien plus anciennes que
ce soit en europe ce qui se passe en
retrait à côté de chez nous voilà réunis
en poisson soja qui est très complet que
j'aie une partie du financement vient
justement de caution à l'écologie elle
est née à droite elle est allée à gauche
on met toujours et d'écologie française
la gauche elle est revenue à gauche où
le nationalisme a fait le chemin inverse
nationalisme est né à gauche il ya ni à
droite
donc attention un petit peu au fondeur
historique du sujet moi je ne veux pas
tout à fait d'accord d'ailleurs sur le
thème libéralisme à propos de macron
messaoud pour en discuter
mais ce que je voudrais revenir quand
même sur des mots posés un petit peu à
ce qui a été dit la france est un pays
on oublie toujours de le dire qui est
exemplaire en matière écologique
on a fait 20 % de moins de gaz à effet
de serre depuis 30 ans le monde dans son
ensemble a fait 60 % de plus je rappelle
qu'on a exactement la même proportion
des gaz à effet de serre que de
population alors qu'on est la sixième ou
septième puissance guerrière est ce que
c'est vrai parce qu'on fait de raser pas
vraiment vous pouvez dire ça va dessus
mais connaît pas exemplaire parce que
par exemple le
l'administration française parle en
finançant edf et d'un fils ans des
énergies fossiles par exemple et donc
est ce qui pollue énormément et depuis
quand le nucléaire contribue au
réchauffement climatique
ah mais non mais non j'ai pas dit ça je
vous ai parlé d'énergie fossile et
d'agir chaque fois ci c'est quand vous
avez cherché de l'uranium dans des pays
étrangers puisque la france n'est pas du
tout aidé pendant fin des quand même de
l'uranium étrangers pour ces deux
centrales nucléaires
donc à partir de la finance et des
énergies fossiles et zinal x side sont
très très polluant et quand par exemple
vous allez la plus grande entreprise
française et un délai de rigueur
l'uranium fouilles pour le nucléaire
le nucléaire contribue au réchauffement
climatique non je vous dis juste que le
cours de la traditionnelle je vous dis
je des coûts d'extraction des gaz ils
ont été faits par le giec est signalé
également mais également aux oukases du
temps était l occasion le carburant des
centrales nucléaires aujourd'hui est
extrait donc d'endroits où ils ont
d'abord eu un bon produit pour le
prendre
attendez il ya des chiffres il ya le
giec mais bien sûr j'ai un monsieur giec
a démontré que l'énergie nucléaire tout
compris pour lui moins que l'éolien par
exemple en rien l jeu beewi html oui
mais un mais je vous ai marre que les
énergies fossiles et nucléaires et
autres nommé l'argent pas que c'est le
problème mais vous parlez d'uranium du
bon sens mais ne va pas ce que je vais
parler pendant des heures mais il a
d'autres à l'énergie et d'extraction et
donc les paroles quand on finance aussi
aujourd'hui des produits pétroliers une
chose comme ça vous savez très bien que
ça ses textes relatant d'or de la france
est plutôt a plutôt un très bon bilan et
donc commençons par là peut-être et ne
ménageant pas tous les problèmes
écologiques et ne mélangeons pas
écologie qui est le nouveau nom de
l'anti capitalisme en france pour cam
appeler les choses par leur nom
un donc succès sur le nucléaire 80 % des
français pensent que le nucléaire
contribue au réchauffement climatique
c'est une belle énergie qui contribuent
le moins bon donc il ya véritablement
une désinformation dont nicolas hulot
d'ailleurs été un des grands genres
castrateur il ya eu dix ans il y à une
désinformation du débat public sur ces
questions je suis désolé encore une fois
je prends les chiffres du giec
non le nucléaire en revanche pose
d'autres problèmes le problème on va
faire du bien mais je voulais rappeler
quelques évidences mais ce qui me paraît
politiquement plus important ce qui est
très frappant et c est pour faire le
lien avec le sujet précédent c'est le
fait qu emmanuel macron mais à son
agenda de la fin du quinquennat
deux sujets la sécurité et
l'écologie est alors qu on fait comment
faire ce sujet pour séduire de la
bassesse et la capture du 7 mai ça
s'appelle une magnifique à renommer des
teams qui me contredira pas
triangulation triangulation chez les
verts avec l'énergie triangulation
pourquoi pour une raison quelconque on
ne veut pas évoquer mais qui est
peut-être qu'on peut être un peu tabou
encore mais que peut-être qu emmanuel
macron à a des doutes sur 2022
c'est à dire que s'il a par exemple un
candidat vert ce qui paraît probable
candidat vert assez fort le premier tour
un candidat de droite qui serait assez
forts du premier tour et évidemment vous
savez qui qui serait de toute façon très
fort il a un risque de ne pas être
deuxième tour donc il est il paraît je
crois qu'il faut quand même aussi voir
ça et c'est pas du tout d'ailleurs
encore une fois criminelle de penser à
ça en politique
il a donc besoin d'un certain nombre de
voies vertes et d'un certain nombre de
voix de droite
sinon il ya même le risque pour lui vous
a vu sa popularité
mais alors la question c'est est ce que
est ce que arnaud bédié est-ce que c'est
compatible en termes de sociologie
électorale
c'est très compliqué régalien écologie
oui enfin ça peut l'être mais ce n'est
en fait qu'est ce qu'il fait il
réinvente le en même temps c'est à dire
qu'il prend un marqueur de droite en
principe de droite dure ça reste à
démontrer la sécurité est un marqueur en
principe de gauche qui est
l'environnement
donc ils pensent en effet de ce produit
là trianguler et permettre d'élargir son
assise son assise sociaux de sociologie
électorale
mais là où je rejoins finalement ce que
vous dites c'est vrai que le problème
des manuels macro aujourd'hui et c'est
un problème qui est vraiment la vie est
suffisamment pointer les lois c'est que
sa présence au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle n'est pas du tout assuré
contrairement à ce qu'on pense les
hackers exemple de lionel jospin
totalement et on en est on en est on en
est là aujourd'hui parce que finalement
il est sur une base sociologique qui est
assez étroite
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron et quand on
regarde les dernières les dernières
études d'opinion on voit que non
seulement il a dévissé depuis très
longtemps à gauche marie messier et qui
commence à dévisser au centre droit et à
droite et que 80% des électeurs ne
veulent
ni de macron ce sondage est important
c'est mal fait mais si je me sens déjà
là outre ce sondage et outre les idées
qu'on peut se faire sur la présence ou
non les manuels macron au deuxième tour
je crois qu'il ya là aussi un changement
de cadre sur le rapport entre la
sécurité et l'écologie il suffit de voir
le nombre de candidats eux élevé qui
intègrent dans leurs campagnes des
préoccupations sécuritaires ce qui
n'était pas du tout le cas avant et donc
chez eux mêmes les écologistes et à
paris y a qu'à voir les retournements
d'anne hidalgo qui assure la question de
la police municipale sur la question des
caméras de surveillance sur la question
complètement aussi changé d'avis et on
voit que la cette question de l'écologie
et de la sécurité n'est plus si
incompatibles qu'elle pouvait l'être si
chez nous dit je croirais au tournant
écologique canton nationalisera la sncf
et comme développera massivement et
petites lignes de train à la question
que vous posez d'ailleurs sur twitter on
vous pose la question depuis tout à
l'heure les mesures de protection du
mont blanc annoncée par emmanuel macron
chantal un coup de com ou un vrai
tournant écologique
bon là c'est assez clair 7 85% considéré
que c'était de la communication plus
qu'un mois pour simon